hey what's cracking you conspiracy
theorists i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message for today's
september 29 20
21 and before we do anything else i
normally don't throw to a video clip
this quickly but i'm gonna do it today
nancy pelosi just in the last hour has
come out as a white supremacist not
about a dollar amount the dollar amount
as the president said is zero this bill
will be paid for
white supremacist nancy pelosi and if
that's not disturbing enough just in and
of itself that nancy pelosi's white
supremacist i think we have to show you
the video again her hand appears to be
alien-like
not about a dollar amount the dollar
amount as the president said is zero
this bill will be paid for
so there you have it people nancy pelosi
is not only a white supremacist but also
an alien
breaking news we got four stories for
you uh you guys know greta thundberg
she's the little angry girl who's
lecturing us all about the climate well
she gave a big speech yesterday and man
she is angry and the horrible things
that she would love to do to all of us
uh normal normal people all of us uh
non-believers in her lunacy we're gonna
show you a clip on that uh then there is
a clip going viral on the interweb of
stephen colbert you know this guy he's
one of the five or six clone like late
night hosts who are all uh straight
white men by the way on these networks
they always tell us how racist we are
and you know patriarchy and all that but
they never uh give up their
multi-million dollar jobs or anything
like that
but there's this clip of this colbert
fella
dancing around uh while singing a
vaccination song and i saw the clip and
it's so horrible that i thought i'm
going to show it to my audience that's
how horrible it is we'll show you that
in just a minute then some really
interesting stuff you know we did
two videos yesterday of nba players
talking about vaccines in a very
thoughtful evolved
decent kind of way
and we're going to show you some
former well a former nba player uh
talking about it in a non-evolved decent
kind of way and we're going to juxtapose
yesterday's video with the video i'm
going to show you today
of uh kareem abdul-jabbar and then
finally if you didn't get enough of
nancy pelosi
uh right up top alien white supremacist
nancy wilson we got another story about
her before we get to any of that i want
to talk to you guys about uprising food
you know you guys all know how much i
love food and for those of you who have
been tuning into my show over the past
couple years you know that i've had
various guests who've talked about how
food how our food system is
fundamentally broken and making us sick
at scale fortunately the people at
uprising food are fixing that uprising's
mission is to liberate all of us from a
broken food system that's stealing our
health they've cracked the code on
healthy bread you simply can't find
something this healthy that tastes this
good that's this fresh i received the
starter bundle and apparently my staff
devoured all the chips with only two net
carbs per serving six grams of protein
and nine grams of fiber uprising food
covers paleo to clean keto to simple low
carb to high fiber to dairy free to
grain free lifestyles all uprising
products are baked with real superfood
ingredients almonds mct oil apple cider
vinegar egg white psyllium husk and
olive oil uprising has absolutely nailed
the taste factor on both of their
sourdough s cubes and the crunch factor
on their newly launched freedom chips
love the name which sounds like those
old school or which tastes like those
old school ride chips uh you will
absolutely dig uprising is offering our
listeners ten dollars off the starter
bundle that includes two super food
cubes and four packs of freedom chips to
try go to
uprisingfood.com reuben and the discount
will automatically be applied at
checkout that's uprising u p r i s i n g
food dot com slash ruben to get 10 off
your first purchase of the starter
bundle and now back to me
should we show that uh let's show the
pelosi thing one more time i mean you
know they're always telling us we're
white supremacists we're signaling what
we showed yesterday that that biden when
he was talking about his 3.5 trillion i
think is going to cost zero he did one
of these and one more time with the
pelosi thing not about a dollar amount
the dollar amount as the president said
is zero
her hand actually looks like the
tentacle of the alien from independence
day i'm pretty certain anyway let's move
on to greta thundberg you all know greta
thunder greta how dare you thunberg this
is a young woman who the left and the
sort of mainstream establishment has
decided is the end-all be-all when it
comes to climate change and she really
hates everyone before her for doing
horrible things to the earth and only if
we gave her and her cohorts enough power
and money they could convert us all into
wonderful green super beings something
to that effect anyway yesterday she was
giving a speech at the youth for climate
event and i thought this was worth
playing not that i really want to pay
any attention to her
but really not only listen to her but
the tone and the tenor look on her face
and everything else and i think it sort
of
belies something much more dangerous
beneath it take a look
[Applause]
there is no planet b
there is no planet blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
this is not about some expensive
politically correct green act of bunny
hugging or blah blah blah
build back better blah blah blah green
economy blah blah blah
net zero by 2050 blah blah blah net zero
blah blah blah climate neutral blah blah
blah this is all we hear from our
so-called leaders
words
words that sound great
but so far
has led to no action
our hopes and dreams drown in their
empty words and promises
of course we need constructive dialogue
but they've now had 30 years of blah
blah blah and where has that led us what
do we want
when do we want it
what do we want
when do we want it
okay i don't even think i have to
address anything that she said there in
her blah blah blah speech but i wanted
to show it because of the the tone
and the anger and then the masked clones
all applauding her at the end as she's
telling us how everyone before her
are basically evil that's what she's
saying they've had their chance now ours
chance now it's our chance like just
imagine if this girl had enough power
the horrible things that she would do to
people like i'm not
gonna be the only one who could see like
little
sort of uh imagery of hitler speaking up
there right like there was some
these people that think that they can
control the world and if you just gave
them enough money and enough power they
could do it man we have unearthed
something so horrible by by our elite
class um and our intellectual class
being so dishonest with us for so long
we have unleashed something that
basically every western nation is under
attack
from every which direction
but that anger of that little girl uh
it's it's just disturbing
anyway i wanted to just show you that
because it's just like
where are the adults we we need some
adults which actually is a perfect segue
to a guy who's absolutely not an adult
and i'm going to owe you an apology
after this so this stephen colbert clip
was going viral today this is from his
show last night it's him dancing around
with vaccines it's about a minute long
that's all we're going to show you and i
just want to apologize in advance for
this
[Music]
let's see
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
vaccine
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so i want to be very clear
about something first off i do apologize
for showing that secondly if you thought
anything there was enlightening or
interesting or funny i henceforth ban
you from watching this program we can we
can't have people like you
the unsullied we can't have you watching
this show uh what you might have found
interesting about that was not any of
the just it's so gross it's just so
gross imagine if trump was president and
the entire political and media machine
supported trump's ideas and there were
dancing vaccinated people around a late
night host they would everyone else
would be screaming that this is
government propaganda i mean all right
you guys get you get all that but did
you notice that no one in the audience
is wearing a mask now i have no doubt
they forced them all to be vaccinated
and
i think they shoot that in new york city
that's in the old letterman
building if i'm not mistaken the old ed
sullivan theater
so i'm sure they had to show their
vaccine passport but we are being told
that people with vaccines are still
getting sick they're still transmitting
it old joe biden when he was getting his
booster shot on that theater set
yesterday or the day before he was
wearing a mask while the other guy was
wearing a mask this is all by design
this intentionally confusing messaging
where some people can be vaccinated some
people don't have to be vaccinated some
people can wear masks rich people can go
to met gala events like aoc and not be
mass while the workers have to be
uh masked you know they're gonna scream
that vaccines you now you need booster
shots but they'll have an audience full
of people that are not wearing masks and
yet if there was an anti-vaxx
rally they'd scream that it was a super
spreader event or if there was just any
political rally that wasn't a lefty
political rally but i'd more uh more
broadly talk about this uh this
ridiculous clip just to show you how
horrible
mainstream
comedy has become these people that man
thinks he's a comedian and jimmy kimmel
blackface jimmy kimmel thinks he's a
comedian
and last week by the way i think some of
you know this uh greg gutfeldt i was on
greg gutfeld show on wednesday night in
new york city uh i believe on thursday
night or might have even been on
wednesday night it was wednesday night
it was it was wednesday night on the
very same night that i was on greg
gutfeld's show
all of the late-night show hosts except
for gutfeld so talking about colbert
and kimmel and who's the fat guy on cbs
that australian kid or corden or cardin
or whatever his name is and trevor noah
on the daily show that nobody watches
anymore but you're not allowed to say
that otherwise you'd be called racist
they all did a climate night and it was
just an abject disaster nobody watched
it meanwhile i was on gut fell that
night and gut fell greg gutfeld he's got
about five people that work for his show
i mean i know the show pretty intimately
they got a makeup girl he's got like one
writer they got a booker
all great people fantastic people
they're crushing it they are number one
in late night because you've basically
got
a bunch of leftist clones who only know
how to preach to the choir uh and
gretvel doing a largely unscripted show
that's edgy and kind of fun and a little
sort of off the wall and ridiculous is
now number one in late night so anyway i
do apologize for having to uh taken that
minute of your life away
and again if you thought it was
interesting or funny or informative in
any way you cannot watch this show
anymore i can't i can't have people like
you watching this show uh all right
we're plowing through today uh story
number three um you know these clowns
over at cnn uh this uh chris cuomo guy
and this don lemon guy well they
actually confess through projection
more than any duo in the history of the
world every time they're talking about
someone else they're actually talking
about themselves don't believe me take a
look but there are a lot of things that
are felonious that you're letting get by
just because it works for your business
model yeah and the time has come for
them we have to flip it and show us that
you can't do what you're being asked to
do the most egregious of it all though
is what you said it's the people who
have the biggest platform on social
media they're all righties they're all
righties they're all of them varieties
and listen even in if you want to call
it legacy media even even some of the
conservative media they do the same
thing
they have no um
no they have no real protocol
they have no real structure in what they
they say what they want they put
headlines and things and write about
things they say it's opinion yeah this
is all apparently that most people most
people we would never even
put it on
give it the light of day because that's
because we have something accountability
that's the fox force the whole nighttime
lineup is entertainment all right but
fox and social but they said then they
shouldn't put news behind it and social
media should do the same thing they
should not just be able to put things
out there and
with you know because they know
god they are such liars right like
that's confession through projection
they are saying exactly what they do
they lie
for ratings to make money and keep
everyone in a constant state of panic
and anger and then they project no it's
only the other people doing it right
it's only fox that does that it's only
those righties on social media i mean
they obviously are threatened by people
like me like that's just how it is you
people watching this have at least half
a brain we've done polls and it turns
out that half of my people have half a
brain you can crunch the numbers on that
but they lie about absolutely everything
i mean these are the same people who
lied i mean you guys all know this right
they lied about the covington kids uh
being racist they lied about brett
kavanaugh being a serial rapist they
lied about the russia hoax they lied
about jesse smollett they lie and lie
and lie and lie and lie that's all they
do they do it for business and for
political purposes and to brainwash the
masses
i do not sit here and pretend that i am
a journalist i wake up in the morning i
send a couple stories to my producer
michael he sends a couple stories back
to me we talk about it for a little bit
and i say all right these are the three
or four things that i want to give an
opinion on today right i'm not telling
you i'm fact-finding in the in the field
and pretending that i'm a journalist but
those guys are pretending that they're
journalists they're tv people who put on
a jacket right so they look kind of
professional they put on ties too i
could put on a die and i could get fake
newsman glasses like uh well bill maher
is wearing now but like anderson cooper
and the rest of them um and and they
pretend that they're journalists but
they're actually activists and not
really
journalists so they lie about everything
what i thought was really interesting
there is though is the is the threat
part so fox they're saying has no
journalistic integrity but they somehow
do i i have no doubt uh that if we were
calling it pound for pound like if we
were just like really racking up big lie
and big narrative in terms of who's
doing more lying there's no doubt that
cnn is doing more lying on a day-to-day
basis than foxes and fox does put on
counter voices as well but i'm not even
making it about that i mean the more
interesting part of this is that what
lemon was saying there at the end you
know then these righties on social media
they're allowed to just say whatever
they want and ah now we've got the
interesting part of this you don't like
the competition and if only big tech
could help you shut down some of our
voices
then you would have a monopoly on truth
wouldn't you lemon i mean these people
are just absolutely ridiculous but
listen to them when they say what they
mean they think they're journalists they
think they have a monopoly on truth and
they are hinting to the overlords take
out the competition and i have no doubt
that as time goes by you know as we
constantly see the divide of truth
getting bigger and bigger and bigger
that chasm between what is true and what
we're allowed to talk about as that gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and the
narrative continues to collapse they are
going to have to ban more of us right
they are going to have to shadowban and
algorithmically depress things and
de-boost and re-rank and all of the
crazy orwellian terms that you now all
know they're going to have to do more
and more of that because too many of us
are questioning things right that's what
we talked about yesterday like you're
allowed to still ask questions these
people don't want you asking questions
they want you to hear their fake stories
and hear them read their fake stories
and for you to believe it
that's not really what i want to do
it really is not uh man these guys it's
just it's just bad news stop watching
cnn
there's your clip for today
uh okay uh we got one more for you so
you know yesterday we played these two
videos from nba players bradley deal of
the washington wizards and jonathan
isaac of the orlando magic talking about
vaccines and the and the video by
jonathan isaac
was particularly interesting i thought
because he's very calm and measured he
talks about being young and physically
fit and having covet and natural
antibodies he talks about personal
choice he really does it in a sort of
evolved interesting way we showed you an
extended clip of it yesterday but i want
to just show you about a 30-second clip
of it right now
what is it about the vaccine that that
makes you
uh
hesitant to to to get it uh i i would
start with um i've had covet um in the
past and so our understanding of
antibodies of natural immunity has uh
changed a great deal from the onset of
the pandemic and is still evolving um
i understand that the vaccine would um
help if you catch covet and uh you'll be
able to have less symptoms um from
contracting it but with me having covert
in the past and having antibodies um
with my current age group and a fitness
physical fitness level um it's not
necessary
okay so if you want to watch the more
extended version of that we played it
yesterday the reason i'm playing it
again today is because obviously what
you're seeing there is a thoughtful
interesting individual who is
non-judgmental trying to
talk about this stuff in a calm way well
now we've got and i hate to show you a
clip from don lemon's show
former nba superstar and uh pilot of uh
co-pilot of the plane and airplane
kareem abdul-jabbar talking about
unvaccinated nba players and i want you
to listen to the difference in tone and
tenor of what he's saying
i think they should be disciplined uh i
don't think that they are
behaving like good teammates or good
citizens um
this is a war that we're involved in and
masks and uh vaccines
they are the weapons that we use to to
fight this war
and uh when you're not gonna
be cooperative with that uh
you're working against the effort
to make everybody safe and uh you know
we can't have that that
that doesn't work for everybody
you know i'm actually really sad to say
this you know i'm an old school nba fan
but kareem abdul-jabbar is just a
ridiculous human being at this point
what what jonathan isaac said there was
true and again watch the watch the more
extended version of it from yesterday's
show if you want um and it was
thoughtful what kareem is saying is do
what we want it doesn't matter if you
have immunity already it doesn't matter
if you're young and healthy and eat
right and any of that stuff do what we
want because we want you to do it and if
you don't do it you're not a good person
now i would like to know and maybe
kareem or don lemon could do a little
research on this how many nba players
have transmitted covid to other nba
players during the games where they're
often sweating on each other and
spitting on each other and you know you
can
go to block a shot and your nails could
get on somebody and they start bleeding
was there a massive outbreak by nba
players young person to young person the
peak of physical performance that's what
the shape that these guys are in did
that ever happen but kareem doesn't care
about that because we're watching this
sort of
massive
brain
experiment happening to everybody where
everyone seemingly that is mainstream at
this point just wants to go along with
what they are told so it does not matter
the same people who will tell you that
they believe in science which is why
kareem i suppose believes in the vaccine
and the masks and all that he believes
in science well why isn't he then
talking about young healthy people and
people who have had covet and natural
immune and everything else but he wants
you to be a good person and speaking of
good people you're not going to believe
this we found video of kareem
abdul-jabbar saying the complete reverse
when it had to do with people protesting
about racial justice
i'm really pleased to see
the diversity of all the people that
that have taken to the streets and have
not gone home
that to me is extraordinary i never
thought i'd live to see that and i'm
glad to see that a very diverse
cross-section of america understands
that you know systemic racism
it's a cancer and
we can't live with it and we have to
figure out ways to eliminate it you get
what we just did there kareem
abdul-jabbar was very excited when all
sorts of people some wearing masks some
weren't were protesting against systemic
racism he liked that diverse
cross-section of people getting out
there and about to protest racism tear
down america down with the patriarchy
but now
now that we're not really talking about
systemic racism anymore right we've got
biden in charge you know it's not trump
anymore so we're not a racist country
anymore i suppose something like that um
so the you know we're not rioting in
that regard anymore that would be too
much to handle biden solved racism i
suppose uh but now he's lecturing nba
players who are young thoughtful in this
case the two guys of the videos that i
played yesterday two young uh black men
who i believe are entitled to their
opinion um he thinks they're bad people
so when it when it was for racial
justice which he's for then get out
there folks spread the disease be a good
human diversity and when it ain't you're
a bad person
kareem you're a bad person sorry i don't
know how else to look at it if you think
things only spread if you think viruses
only spread
when it fits your political narrative
the problem is on you there's a virus in
your head
that's far worse than the covet virus
actually we are going to do one more
story i just remembered we threw that
pelosi clip up top we've got a little
more on pelosi because every now and
again
our public leaders say things that
they're not supposed to say they say the
quiet part out loud as i referenced
yesterday with that movie wizard of oz
and the munchkins and i'm not going to
get into that whole munchkin orgy thing
again because i'm sure many of you left
and then an hour of your life was sucked
away uh but
nancy pelosi uh
just sort of slipped this is just a very
subtle slip in what she's saying here
well you listen
keep government open we intent we have
to do those imminently uh
more in
even
to address the full
obama agenda of building back better
with and i love to say building that
better
nancy
nancy you just said the quiet part out
loud you do know that joe biden is the
guy that we're supposed to think is
president and in charge of everything
allow me to quote her keep government
open to address the full obama agenda of
building back better
she meant biden but she said obama and
you know often this is now coming up all
the time because anyone with half a
brain realizes that biden is not in
charge right he's just not he's the
figurehead that they put out there to
read often poorly off the teleprompter
and mumble and stumble through anything
that he's doing but you are now seeing
what this really is about and this is
about
obama basically getting a third term
it's obama's agenda of building back
better it's strange i remember those
eight years when obama was president did
he ever say building back better
i don't think so
but he did once say i'm sure many of you
have seen the interview where he said he
would love to have a third term he knows
he can't have a third term so he'd love
to just pull the strings from behind so
every now and again they tell you
exactly what they're doing so if you
wonder where this radical crazy leftist
progressive ever expanding state for 3.5
trillion dollars equals zero
more and more climate shutdowns and
masks and lockdowns and mandates and
everyone will be backed and now we just
saw this morning
i just saw it before we started uh that
the administration is going to start
punishing companies that don't make sure
that all of their employees are
vaccinated we'll see if they start with
you know companies at 100 people or 50
people or a thousand people who knows
what they're going to do but you know
that that'll keep moving once they get
it to 100 people they'll get it to 50
people and 25 people and 10 people and
they literally won't let you work alone
if you work alone remotely in your
basement they will come for you too so
this has something to do with barack
obama and his third term i don't think
that is a conspiracy theory nancy pelosi
said it right there obama's build back
better and obama himself said he wanted
a third term
these people are gross
guys i'm in a new prageru doc that came
out this morning it's called restricted
how big tech is taking away your freedom
you can watch it right now at
prageru.com
also part two of my interview with jack
posobiac uh is up on the youtube we talk
all about about china about all the
stuff all the stuff that we that i'm
always talking about here we kind of do
a little of everything including a
little star wars stuff oh and on friday
i am excited we are going to do a little
bit of a
idw reunion you know the idw basically
which sort of caught the world on fire
uh and most
much of it was sort of you know
basically founded and took place in my
garage um it sort of imploded i think
there's many reasons for that but there
are a couple people that were associated
with it that i think are still doing
some good work gad sad will be joining
me on friday michael shermer and we have
a call out to one or two other people
so we're going to get a little bit of
the old band back together and see what
happens
so i hope you'll tune in for that
as i said a couple times in the last few
days we now do live chat on my locals
community during the show so if you want
to text chat with people because we
don't do the live chat on youtube
because it's just a bot and troll fest
so if you want to chat with other sane
human beings actual real people you can
join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and you can do
it from your desktop or you can download
the locals app uh later today i'm
interviewing blake masters who's running
for
senate in arizona looking forward to
talking to him he's big on fighting the
big tech monster making sure elections
are secure you know real crazy
right-wing stuff and uh and then i got a
couple a couple media hits and some
other stuff to do what i have to tell
you everything i'm doing all day long
okay you know
all right guys have a great day see you
tomorrow